on continue cette fois-ci donc les 5 et
6 mai aura lieu la finale de
championnats de France de badminton au
Palais des Sports d'Élancourt et pour en
parler avec nous Éric Mayer vous êtes le
président du comité d'organisation des
plaisirs comment se déroule ces deux
jours donc ces deux jours on va voir
donc les quatre meilleures équipes
françaises qui vont venir Élancourt donc
ils se sont départagés sur 10 journées
de championnat les deux premiers de
chaque poule donc sont qualifiés
demi-finale croisée en donc le vendredi
et final pour descendites de champion de
France Top 12 de badminton le samedi
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler ces quatre
équipes justement donc un Chambly Arras
Fos-sur-Mer et Mulhouse et comment est
le niveau à peu près comment vous le
jugez les joueurs qui vont dire je pense
qu'on sont à peu près tous dans le top
100 mondial au niveau de leur de leur
spécialité
c'est vraiment
là on a un très très gros plateau
peut-être unique pour le club alors
unique non puisque on l'a déjà organisé
les finales Top 12 en 2009
c'était pas la même le badinton n'avait
pas la même
[Musique]
l'impact en fait on était un petit peu
moins connu donc là maintenant je pense
que c'est réellement à une vitrine pour
le club de Lancôme pour la ville
d'Élancourt et donc
on espère faire un très bel événement
pour montrer que le badminton est un
sport très très intéressant
on a le sentiment que ça se démocratise
vraiment le badminton on envoie un petit
peu de partout il va avoir les JO aussi
qui vont peut-être aider à la promotion
du badminton ce que vous en pensez c'est
vrai que bon déjà le badminton au niveau
scolaire devenir des premiers sports
scolaires donc évidemment tout le monde
a fait du badminton dans le lycée ou au
collège donc déjà ça apporte du monde
dans le dans les clubs après il nous
manquait peut-être des des résultats
comment savoir des résultats en double
mix on a une équipe qui est une pierre
française qui est cinquième mondiale
donc on commence à avoir quelques
résultats
si on pouvait faire des supers résultats
aux JO en France je pense que là ça
serait réellement un très beau tremplin
et alors justement ce titre champion de
France donnera le droit au vainqueur de
représenter la France lors de la Coupe
d'Europe des Clubs
le champion
défendra les odeurs de la France en
Coupe d'Europe des Clubs donc les
dernières c'était Chambly qui avait le
titre et alors défendre son titre et
alors combien de personnes seront
attendues les 5 et 6 mai alors on a la
chance d'être dans un
palais des sports d'Élancourt qui 1200
places
donc on espère remplir le Palais des
Sports donc les billets sont en vente
sur sur le site du de l'événement donc
je sais pas si
donc on attend on attend un maximum de
monde
on espère avoir c'est vrai qu'on est
pendant les vacances donc les gens
devraient pouvoir venir le vendredi sans
problème pour voir les finales et puis
le samedi ce sera vraiment une belle
fête derrière donc
on attend un maximum de monde
on n'avait pas eu énormément de monde je
crois qu'on avait fait presque pas plus
de 200 entrées sur le week-end mais je
vous dis c'était pas le même le même le
même impact le badminton et surtout
les équipes qui viennent là on a
vraiment des très très bons joueurs
donc là je pense qu'on va être un très
beau spectacle est-ce que c'est vraiment
pour tout le monde vraiment tout le
monde peut venir ah oui oui tout à fait
on prend le plaisir le plus vite on n'a
pas besoin d'avoir un niveau énorme pour
faire pour avoir pour prendre plaisir
Wellington et donc c'est pour ça que
beaucoup de monde accrochent badminton
nous on a dans notre club des sections
compétitions donc là évidemment on a
besoin d'avoir des entraînements etc
pour arriver à un bon niveau mais on a
les section loisirs qui marche très bien
et donc déjà si tous les joueurs de
badminton de l'Île-de-France viennent
sera content
en tout cas merci beaucoup Eric Moyer de
nous avoir partagé ce moment je le
rappelle vous êtes le président du
comité régional des playoffs de
badminton et maintenant on va parler de
football